[Applause]  there's a lot of talk about what this  team can and can't be  in the postseason as you're well aware  what is the potential of this utah group  [ __ ] the talk we just try to be the best  team we can be we try to enjoy the  moment and whatever happens happens  there's a lot of talk about what this  team can and can't be  in the postseason as you're well aware  what is the potential of this utah group  uh [ __ ] the talk we just try to be the  best we can be we try to enjoy the  moment and whatever happens happens  there's a lot of talk about what this  team can and can't be  in the postseason as you're well aware  what is the potential of this utah group  [ __ ] the talk we just try to be the best  we can be we try to enjoy the moment and  whatever happens happens